today's questions from Victoria in New
Jersey my husband and I are a major
credit card that around $40,000 on
multiple credit cards and don't know how
to get out we're considering
consolidating all the cards onto one
card and pay monthly with a zero percent
APR and no transfer fees do you think
this is a good idea
probably not here's why you are trying
to fix your credit card debt with your
interest rate the interest rate is not
your problem your problem is that you
are spending everything you make instead
of putting it on the debt and so let's
sit down and do a written budget let's
cut out eating out let's cancel the
vacation let's stay home turn down the
cable from $300 a month to a basic
package let's sell some stuff have a
garage sale let's get out the scissors
and cut up the credit cards so they
never grow back and let's get very very
serious as if your freaking life
depended on it about putting some money
on this debt now if you only put $5,000
a month on this it'll be gone at 8
months if you only put $2,500 only to be
gone in 16 months that's what matters
here the interest rate is not your
problem your problem is you spend
everything you make and that's what
you've got to fix now once you're doing
that and you've had three months of
success you list your credit cards
smallest card to largest card and you
put all the attention on the smallest
card you pay minimum payments on
everything but the little one and you
attack the little one and when you start
seeing yourself having some success for
the first time maybe in your entire life
with money you will get more excited
more hopeful you will cut deeper take
more extra jobs and you're the result is
the math starts to work even better
because the more money you making the
less of it you spend the more money you
have to put on the debt and that happens
when you believe
the more you believe the deeper you do
these things the deeper your sacrifice
the crazier you get according to your
broke friends the more you believe the
more you pour gas on the fire and that's
what paying off the little one does it
increases your hope it increases your
belief that you're actually going to win
now once you're doing all of that if you
wanted to go to a 0% it'd be ok but
let's let's talk about it ok let's say
that it's 15% ok that's $6,000 a year
what I just described was that you were
gonna be out of debt in 12 to 18 months
I don't know your income so I don't know
if that's gonna be true but that's what
I just described and so if you're out of
debt in 12 to 18 months this saves you
$6,000 well if you send me $6,000 I'll
keep it that's a lot of money I don't
care who you are but $6,000 does not
solve a $40,000 problem thus the $6,000
is not the problem and so don't get so
caught up in I did something so I don't
have to do anything because I moved it
over here I got 0% and guess what it
still didn't go away cuz you never
really address the core problem which is
you and you got to address the person in
your mirror if I can make the guy in my
mirror behave you can be skinny and rich
but he likes chocolate chip cookies it's
a problem it's just a problem but I know
what the problem is it's not the evil
chocolate chip company it's not the evil
cookie company it's not the evil woman
that makes the chocolate chip cookies
that smell so dadgum good it has nothing
to do with those people it's not their
fault
no one taped me to the bed with duct
tape and force-fed me chocolate chip
cookies I made a choice to eat them and
I have to make a choice to not eat them
or I'm gonna be as big as this freaking
building and so you have to decide and
you're not a victim of anything except
your own stinky habits me too me too I'm
not any different
but this is how you address this issue
so that's this is what debt
consolidation doesn't work that's not
the problem it's the symptom you're
treating the symptom
you can't treat the symptom you gotta
treat the problem the core problem is
dis organization I'm buying crap I can't
afford with money I don't have to
impress people I don't even really like
I'm impulsive I'm childish I whine and
stomp my foot and has sticked my lip out
like I'm four years old on the cereal
aisle and say I worked so hard I deserve
it
we'll call the wambulance seriously
don't we all do this we all do it we all
act like we're four years old at times
and if the four-year-old you´d is not
controlled by the 34 year old emotional
you then you're gonna be broke your
whole life that's called growing up me
too
I'm not any different turning 60 this
year and nothing inside of me feels like
it nothing inside of me feels like
anything but that little four-year-old
boy if something doesn't go my way I'm
just like you the only difference is you
got to decide if I'm going to control
that little brat that lives inside of me
shut up kid the answer is no I'm gonna
learn to delay pleasure which is a sign
of maturity I'm gonna learn to work like
no one else so that later I can work
like no one else I'm gonna learn to be
outrageously generous I'm gonna be
disciplined self-control is a fruit of
the Spirit you can't say Dave REMS you
changed my life because I have never
stood in anybody's house and kept them
from spending money I did not change
your life I convinced you to do it
that's all I did I made you believe that
if you did this stuff you would win and
I'm right if you do this stuff you will
win and if you don't do this stuff you
won't win it really is not rocket
science but no one's going to duct-tape
you to your bed and keep you from
spending on a stupid credit card you've
got to decide you've got to be a
grown-up you got to make the call you
got to buckle up buttercup
that's what's going on here and that's
what we have to do all of us it's so
hard Victoria it's so hard for all of us
and it's why I'm still sitting here
doing this same exact show thirty years
later it's the same show a little less
country I'm a little more polished I'm a
little better at the thing I've gotten
I've developed my craft a little over
the year years but the debt snowball
hasn't changed the budget hasn't changed
the baby steps haven't changed because
they didn't need to change they weren't
the problem
I don't like Dave Ramsey no you don't
like you you don't like what you're
doing and I am telling you what you're
doing and it's convicting your little
butt and you don't like that that's what
you don't like I don't take it personal
on people hate on Dave Ramsey I don't do
rumors you do rooms he's a charlatan he
rips people off yeah I ripped people off
I do a radio show for free kind of
moronic statement as that stuff so no I
don't rip anybody off I'll show you
exactly what you can do sometimes people
buy a book from me they're showing me
exactly what you can do sometimes people
go through Financial Peace University
that convince you you can do it cuz
you're with a whole bunch of other
people doing it and you're working
together with your spouse for the first
time in your married life and you go be
successful yeah and I charge money for
that unapologetically but you can listen
to this show for free you can watch
YouTube for free you can download the
podcast for free billions of minutes of
the Dave Ramsey show we've been watched
on YouTube that's wild when you think
about it
billions and you know what I charge you
guys for that zip so it's up to you what
are you gonna do what are you gonna do
it's only 40,000 dollars and the scope
of your life that's not much but this is
your turning point
is you a man or is you a mouse is you a
woman or is you a wimp let's get with it
kiddo time to grow up buckle up
buttercup get her done